[Music]
good morning or good afternoon ladies
and gentlemen depending on where in the
world you are my name is jan dolce
instrument i'm pleased to welcome you to
our latest webinar in the series
scientists empowering scientists today's
webinar is hosted again by lab roots
sponsored by sutter instrument
and we're going to talk about retinal
electrophysiology today about combining
light beams and how to deal with noise
after very brief introduction
i will in uh
introduce the speakers and then the
first speaker will be telega attatos he
will talk about enlightening your
research with the lambda 721
the second speaker will be fatima abbas
from the university of utah
she will talk about
trans retinal signals from postmortem
human eyes and what they can tell us
about vision and then i will be the last
speaker
and i will talk about noise what is
hidden under the noise in
electrophysiology
and at the end of the webinar we will
have a question and answer session for
your questions you have
a question box that is on a button on
the toolbar that should be on the left
of your screen
please if you ask a question mention
which speaker it is directed to
sometimes that's easy to guess but we
don't want to have to necessarily
guess and
all questions will either be addressed
during the live q and a session at the
end of this webinar or we will get back
to you offline by email
also use the questions
function for technical issues if you
have
no
audio or something like that there will
be somebody answering that
in terms of documentation materials
today all we have is a video of the
webinar that will be available on
labruts.com soon after the end of the
webinar and then late somewhat later we
will have it on the sutter instrument
youtube channel and for our customers in
china also on the yuco channel
everybody who signed up for the webinar
will be notified by email when the
southern youtube and yuku videos are
live
let me introduce today's speakers ladies
first
first speaker
the second speaker first introduced uh
is fatima abbas who graduated at the
king's college london
in 2016 doing indivo calcium imaging on
zebrafish then continued working on
zebrafish during her postdoc at yale
university
and since 2017 has been doing
postdoctoral research at the university
of ut utah
where she
uses in vivo erg electro retinogram
um and that is the research that she's
going to talk about today
the first speaker is going to be telega
certain who graduated in
on at queen's college new york in 1987
joined instatek the same year initially
in i.t engineering support and then
through several functions eventually to
be the general manager until instateque
was acquired by hicka instruments in
2010 in 2007
and since 2015
um
i have the pleasure and honor to call
telly my colleague etc instrument where
he works in technical support and
product development
myself i graduated in marburg in germany
doing electrophysiology with insect
scinzilla
in 2003 axon instruments hired me and
relocated me to california
i stayed on through several mergers with
action instruments and then later
molecular devices until 2011 when i
joined sutter instrument as the product
manager for laser-based micropipette
pullers
in
2012 to
2014 i worked for hika electronic where
i met telly
and
since 2014 i'm with sutter instrument
where i'm the product manager for patch
clamp systems and since the beginning of
this year also the director of marketing
with that let me go to the first talk
and that is a talk by telegazatos
enlighten your research with the
lambda721
hello everyone my name is telegradzatos
my talk today titled in line your
research with lambda721 will provide an
overview of one of sutter's newest
products the lambda 721 beam combining
system
before we get started i would just like
to provide a brief history of the
optical products designed and
manufactured by the sutter instrument
company
it all started with the wheel as it has
for many of man's great innovations over
30 years ago southern engineers set out
to design a reliable fast electrically
quiet computer controlled filter wheel
the result was a lambda 10.
as technology advanced in the field of
imaging so was demand for faster
wavelength switching speeds and the
filter wheel could provide
sutter introduced the lambda dg4 the dg4
was a complete illumination system
offering speed and versatility for rapid
wavelength switching in less than a
millisecond
this high speed switching was achieved
by using dual scanning mirrors mounted
on galvanometers directing the light
through one of the interference filters
for wavelength selection this high speed
dance was truly artistry in motion
with the knowledge that was gained with
the illumination system of the dg-4
stand-alone high-power xenon arc lamp
light sources were introduced next
today led technology is the basis for a
constantly expanding optical product
line
led based light sources have the
advantage of quiet vibration free and
long life operation
in addition newer wavelength leds are
constantly being produced expanding the
range of applications that include
fluorescent microscopy and optogenetics
a few years ago the optical beam
combiner technology was introduced the
lambda obc combines separate light
sources with different spectra into a
single common output beam the patented
pentagon shape of the lambda obc keeps
the size of the beam combiner small and
the optical pathway short and efficient
allowing lower output losses than
previously possible
here we have an illustration of how the
pentagon works each light source is
collimated before entering the optical
path through a bandpass filter these
thin film band pass filters reflect
greater than 90 percent of the
out-of-band light if the band pass of
each light source does not overlap then
it can be used for both attenuation and
reflection of the light from the other
light sources
up to four combinations of light sources
and filters can be arranged to a single
compact obc pentagon
the led light sources combined with the
pentagon design provided the technology
for the ultimate in versatility and
speed for our beam combining systems the
lambda 421 was the first iteration of
this combined technology
today we have the latest iteration the
lambda 721 which i will describe
the lambda 721 uses a double pentagon
design for combining up to seven
separate led cubes with different
spectra into a single common output beam
common applications include fluorescent
microscopy calcium imaging
fura optogenetics and high speed
wavelength selection
each led cube contains the led
collimating optics and a filter
wavelength selection and beam reflection
is achieved using semrock str filters
the led cubes can be placed in any one
of seven positions without any concern
for specific order
led cubes are easily exchanged and
installed without any tools
the lambda 721 was designed for
flexibility and expandability
should illumination needs change over
time simply ordering and installing
additional led cubes will produce an
entirely different output
the current wavelength options are
extensive as shown in this slide and as
i mentioned earlier constantly evolving
the base lambda 721 controller is
available with either a liquid light
guide or sma one millimeter multi-mode
fiber
epi adapters for most microscopes are
available for a complete list please
visit our website if a specialized
adapter is required sutter has the
capability to custom design the right
one for you
here is a short video of the lambda 721
in action
first a view inside the 721 itself
and then what is seen by the sample at
the objective
here we have an illustration of double
pentagon design used in the lambda 721
the concept is the same as a standalone
obc pentagon but the machining and
packaging is far sexier
even though specific led cube placement
is not a requirement here are a few
suggestions for optimizing light output
the light from position number one goes
directly to the device output without
being reflected this might be the
preferred position for the source with
the greatest desired output
the filter for the seventh light source
is not used as a reflective surface and
could be used with led cubes with
broader outputs
in configurations with fewer than seven
light sources led cubes should be filled
from lowest to highest number of
reflections to ensure the greatest
possible light output these are just
suggestions as you can use any placement
that works best for your experimental
needs
the next part of my presentation is a
quick user's guide reference for the
lambda 721
the first thing we need to do is to
properly install the light guide as a
safety precaution never look directly
into the light guide or point it onto a
reflective surface on the lambda 721
output simply insert the light guide
into the light guide port until the top
of the light guide sleeve is flush with
the top of the port as shown in the
picture labeled correct position
gently tying the lock down screw
to optimize the output intensity the
light beam we need to properly collimate
it on the dovetail adapter
this adjustment is best performed before
connecting the adapter to the microscope
slide the light guide into the adapter
in the same manner with the 721 port
with the lambda 721 powered on and an
led with visible light active point the
adapter's output to a flat wall surface
approximately 10 feet away over those
who prefer meters approximately three
meters
loosen the lock down screw and slide the
light guide in and out until the circle
on the wall has sharp edges and is
uniform as shown in these images
tying the lock down screw power off the
721 and install the adapter onto the
microscope
now that we have the hardware properly
connected let's review the front and
rear panel controls there are only a few
controls that you will need to get
acquainted with on the front panel
on the left hand side we have the led on
off state indicators which are extremely
useful especially when testing
to the right of that is a display which
shows the menu selections and device
status
followed by controls for transversing
and selecting the various menu choices
located on the right and below the
display
finally the light output port
on the rear panel we have bnc input
connectors for led 1-7
ring buffer ttl strobe input bnc
usb interface for computer control
sutter does provide a usb driver as well
as an igor xl for interfacing with a
lambda c721 at no charge and most
importantly the power switch
here is a flowchart of all the menu
selections available in the lambda 721
other than that demo mode the next few
slides will provide a brief tutorial
in lambda 10 mode the lambda 721
responds to the sutter instrument lambda
10x series filter wheel external
commands for controlling the on off
state of each of the seven leds
these external commands are fully
described in the user's manual which is
included with the unit and can also be
downloaded from our website this mode
allows imaging software for example
micromanage that already have support
for our lambda 10x controllers to
interface with a 721 without the need of
any software changes
to activate this mode
first if another mode is active press
off to return to menu selections this
will also be the same step required for
all other modes that i will be
describing later on
turn the selection knob to the lambda 10
prompt appears
press the yes button
which will display the mode's execution
prompt
in ttl mode the on off state of each of
the seven led channels can be controlled
by ttl signaling via one or more of the
seven ttl input bnc connectors on the
rear panel
the state of an led is on when its
corresponding ttl input receives a ttl
high signal which typically is an
amplitude above 2.7 volts and is off
with a ttlo which is typically below 400
millivolts this is the default factory
operation
input polarity can be reversed via dip
switch setting located on the left hand
side panel of the 71.
to enable ttl mode turn the selection
knob until use ttl mode prompt appears
press the yes button followed by the
enter button
the lambda 721 like the lambda 10 3 and
dg4 has an internal ring buffer
the ring buffer provides fast precise
switching between leds via single ttl
input signal
the ring buffer is a circular buffer
memory with space for maximum 100
entries
each entry is an led value
when a trigger pulse is detected on the
strobe input port that led value command
will be executed the next entry is then
primed for execution
to enable ring buffer mode turn the
selection knob until the use ring buffer
prompt appears
press yes
press yes again to to execute the
current counts to the ring buffer the
lambda 721 is now armed waiting for a
strobe trigger
editing the ring buffer can be
accomplished either from the front panel
controls or via software i will only
describe the front panel method
turn the selection knob until the use
ring buffer prompt appears then press
yes
press no to the run existing ring buffer
prompt
followed by yes to edit the ring buffer
the first entry in the ring buffer will
be shown on the display to edit or ana
entries
use a selector knob to adjust the
current entry for all off led one
through seven and end rb which is end
ring buffer
press the next button advances to the
next entry without saving any changes to
the current entry
pressing the enter button saves any
change to the entry and advances to the
next entry
selecting end rb for the entry sets it
to the end of the ring buffer even
though there may be other commands in
memory
pressing off exits ring buffer edit mode
and display setup prompt
the final mode that i would like to talk
about is setup in this mode the power on
state either on or off and the output
power level of an led can be configured
turn the selection knob until the setup
mode prompt appears
press the yes button the display will
show the power settings for the first
led
to change the settings
use a selection knob to adjust power
from 100 to 00
use the on button to turn the led on the
off button to turn it off
the next button advance to the next led
without saving any power level
adjustment or led state the enter button
saves settings and advanced to the next
led
pressing enter on led7 exit setup mode
and goes to the use ring buffer prompt
just a few additional comments that you
may have already seen in our newsletter
for decades the dg4 digi5 high speed
wavelength switchers have been a
favorite of researchers with the
advancements that the lambda 721 optical
beam combining system provides it will
now replace the dg4 dg5 family of
products
lambda 721 offers faster switching
longer lamp life
higher efficiency
more filtered channels smaller footprint
and software compatibility with many
imaging applications
depending on the number of led cubes
installed the lambda 721 would also be a
lower cost alternative
to all our digit 4 digi5 customers i
want to assure you that sutter will
continue to support and service existing
g4 products until we are no longer able
to do the part apps lessons
finally a few suggestions that may be
useful when ordering
first select one of the two base
controller configurations there are two
options available with a light guide or
sma fiber
then select the led cubes with the
wavelengths needed for your experiments
one of our most popular configurations
uses 340 380 480 and 561 nanometer cubes
that combination is well suited for
furore 2 gfp and a variety of green
exciting and red emitting fluorescents
if you need help with selecting the
proper led cube
visit our website
send an email to either info or directly
to our lambda 721 product manager chris
ballard or just go old school and give
us a call we still like that i would
like to thank you for your attention i
do hope that you have found this
presentation useful
thank you very much telly for this um
interesting presentation about the
lambda seven to one light source
um including a lot of step-by-step setup
guidance and things like that let's move
on to our next speaker
fatima abbas from the department of
ophthalmology and visual sciences at the
[ __ ] eye center at the university of
utah
thank you jan and telly and everyone at
sutter instruments for the
invitation
today i'm going to talk about how
in our lab we measure trans retinal
signals in human post-mortem retinas
using sutter instrument products
today most insights into the physiology
of the retina have come from model
organisms
from vertebrates including zebrafish and
salamander
to mammalians such as mouse and macaque
to uh put it extremely simply there are
light sensing neurons called
photoreceptors
which can detect photons through a
phototransduction pathway
these signals are passed on to bipolar
cells
and there is some processing that
happens along the way via horizontal
cells
and amacrine cells
and uh these signals are then passed on
to retinal ganglion cells which are the
outputs of the retina to the brain
so while these model organism studies
have provided invaluable information on
the general principles of how the retina
works we know there are some differences
between species
the mouse for instance is a nocturnal
animal so its retina is predominantly
composed of rod photoreceptors which are
dim light sensing
whereas daylight living animals
including zebrafish have cone-dominated
retinas and these photoreceptors are
much less sensitive but are color
specific
furthermore primates including humans
have a specialized central area of the
retina
which is condominated and responsible
for high acuity vision this is the
macula
whereas the rest of the human retina is
uh rod dominated
so what goes wrong specifically in
disease may be more specific to the
physiology of the primate retina
even within primates such as macaques
there are reports of differences to
human retina specifically in the context
of aging
and among other things
primates as a model organism including
macaque
are very expensive to maintain
and they come with ethical and moral
difficulties in their use
and what's more
there's currently no widely available
primate models of human retinal diseases
so a good example of a disease that's
difficult to model in animals is
age-related macular degeneration
or amd
um the factors influencing its
development human are still not 100
understood
and many of the models are poorly
replicate the physiology that occurs in
human
and this is where we think human donor
eyes can provide a really invaluable
resource for understanding the
development of these retinal disorders
using these tissues has much fewer
ethical implications than animal models
and what's more
these donor tissues can be a source of
primary diseased tissue
so we can study the physiology of these
disorders first hand
in
donor derived tissue
and that's why we really wanted to
establish the criterion protocols to use
these donor human retinas
to study and understand retinal
physiology specifically in humans
and how it might differ from that of
other animals
and also in disease
so how do we measure the function of
retinal neurons in patients
we use a trans retinal signal that the
retina generates in response to light
stimuli
this is the electro retinogram
and you can consider it an equivalent to
what ecg is for measuring the hertz
electrical signaling or even the eeg for
signaling in the brain
and there are several devices that are
used in the clinic to
measure this
they provide a light stimulus and then
measure the electrical responses of the
retina in response to the stimuli so
these photographs show both a
commercially available handheld device
and a
benchtop device that can be used
and to give a very brief and
oversimplified overview of what's
happening during these recordings
if we think about how the retina
transmits light signals
once a light stimulus reaches the
photoreceptors they all respond
simultaneously
and they create a negative voltage
change which you can see here
on this graph
this collective response
is known as an a wave in the erg
so we can quantify the amplitude of
these responses to different light
intensities
to determine the sensitivity of the
photoreceptors but again we can also use
it to track the decline of photoreceptor
function in diseases
shortly after this once the signaling
from photoreceptors is passed on to the
next neuronal population in the circuit
the bipolar cells
we see a positive voltage recorded known
as the b wave
so this is the summed activity of these
bipolar cells
in the entire retina
this combination of being able to
quantify both the function of
photoreceptors and bipolar cells is a
valuable diagnostic tool in the clinic
so more specifically these recordings
provide an objective measure of the rate
of degeneration that's going on in the
retinas of patients
by quantifying these trans retinal
voltages you can
quantify specifically the level of
degeneration that's happened so far and
also track it in the future
so a great example of how this is used
in the clinic is shown here so on the
left here we've got a control response
to a dim white light stimulus which will
stimulate the rod photoreceptors you can
see an a wave from the photoreceptor
response and the b wave from the bipolar
cells on the right however is a response
from a patient with retinitis pigmentosa
and this is where rods degenerate
and we can see that there's no real
responses from the retina to the dim
light stimulus that should produce these
rod responses
so while ergs are useful in the clinic
we can also use them as a tool in
retinal research and not just on humans
this video shows um a custom designed
specimen holder which allows us to
record ergs from retinas isolated from a
variety of different organisms ranging
from zebrafish to mice and even humans
the retinas are perfused with a
physiological medium throughout
recordings
and light stimulus is provided from
above
and we have two electrodes provide
placed above and below the retinal
surface to record these trans retinal
voltage changes
so the graph on the right here shows
examplex vivo ergs taken from a wild
type mouse retina
so these are primarily rod responses
and you can see the increasing responses
in response to the increasing light
intensity given
the negative voltage response is from
the broad photoreceptors and this is
from bipolar cell responses
[Music]
so the question arises why even use ex
vivo erg
well experieng has several advantages
over in vivo erg
for one because we're using retinal
explants
we can supply the retina with many
different pharmacological agents
a great example is dlap4
which blocks signaling from
photoreceptors to bipolar cells
and this allows us to more accurately
measure the photoreceptor response
amplitude without the interference of
the bipolar cell responses
and obviously this would be impossible
in human patients
but also it's more difficult in the
intact animal as you would have to
inject into the
vitreous of the eye
so this also means that this technique
can be an ideal platform for testing
drugs in the retina
and not only that but we can obtain much
higher signal-to-noise ratios using
xvivoyagi since the retina is isolated
from the main sources of noise that we
have in vivo
so this includes signals including the
pulse
and obviously you'd find that normally
in living creatures and
human patients
and this signal to noise ratio enables
us to much more uh thoroughly
investigate the physiology of the
retinal neurons that we're measuring
and uh lastly
we can use the small recording area on
the x vivo erg specimen holder
to record specifically from small
localized areas of the retina
and when it comes to human retinal
physiology this is especially important
since it enables us to record
specifically from for example the macula
of the human retina
to acquire and amplify these trans
retinal voltages we use sutter
instrument amplifier systems
combined with these custom built
specimen holders
in the bimbag lab we've used everything
from the ipa dendrite and d-patch
systems to record ex vivo ergs across
several different publications and
projects
not only this but it provides the added
advantage that we can also carry out uh
experiments using other techniques
including patch clamp electrophysiology
and photoreceptor outer segment
recordings using the exact same systems
the fact that these systems are
relatively compact and self-enclosed
has also enabled us to transport our
equipment equipment across the country
to carry out donor eye recordings for
example in san diego
we also use the analog outputs that the
system provides to control the light
stimuli that we uh
present to the retinas through the
sutter patch software
so we can uh simultaneously control both
data acquisition and stimulus generation
and the such patch software is versatile
enough to allow us to control the custom
wavelength leds that we use to provide
these tightly controlled light stimuli
so the question arises
can we use ex vivo erg to study human
retinal diseases already
we know that many people use postmortem
retina from human donors for studies
that use molecular biology techniques
such as gene expression analyses
or fixed tissue studies involving
immunohistochemistry or electro electron
microscopy
but why does nobody use this tissue to
study the function of the retina in
human retinal disease patients for
example
most of this is because there is an
existing dogma that neurons die rapidly
after
death and most post-mortem organ donor
tissue is collected several hours
post-mortem
so inspired by the work of the sestan
lab at yale on post-mortem pig brain
that they published in 2019
we set about to address these challenges
and misconceptions in the retina
specifically
after extensive preliminary studies
using mouse with post-mortem delay and
uh the longer post-mortem delay research
donor experiments that we carried out
we understood that reduced post-mortem
hypoxia time is crucial for recovery of
retinal neuronal responses
so in collaboration with organ donation
programs
we managed to obtain organ donor ice
specifically after brain death which
reduces death to a nucleation time to
less than 20 minutes after the cessation
of circulation
and to further maintain the integrity of
the eye
we optimize the transportation container
for transporting this tissue to the lab
and it provides a nutrient-rich heavily
oxygenated aims media
once the tissue is in the lab we used ex
vivo g experiments to quantify the
function of the retinal neurons
focusing specifically on photoreceptors
and bipolar cells
we also refined our specimen holder
design shown here to sample from areas
of the retina that's only half a
millimeter in diameter
and this allows us to record responses
from very small subsections of the
macula for instance
and using this new protocol with the
extremely fresh tissue that we could
obtain from organ donors
we reliably recorded intact on bipolar
cell responses in the peripheral retina
as you can see here
so this is an example of responses from
peripheral retina with both a and b
waves present
and they look strikingly like a
mouse retinal response which is also a
rod dominated retina
once we add the drug dlap4 to the
perfusion solution to block bipolar cell
function
we can see that there are much longer
photoreceptor responses which are
produced by rod photoreceptors
and this also confirms that these
positive inflections in the recordings
are indeed on bipolar cell responses
so with this shorter time to a
nucleation we can reliably obtain
bipolar cell responses
and these are a biomarker for the health
of the retina
furthermore
with the specimen hold as much smaller
recording area we can even sample from
smaller locations within the macula
so these are the first reported
recordings specifically from human
macular
on the top these are recordings from the
periphevia
and you can see it has a very visible
rod component seen with these much
longer sustained
uh
responses on the left it when in the
presence of dlap4
the fovea however has a much stronger
cone photoreceptor response which is
this extremely rapid sharp
uh
uh photoreceptor response
so from these responses we can even
identify
the proximity of the retinal punches
that we take to the central fovea based
on the ratio of these longer sustained
rod responses compared to the much
shorter rapid cone responses
now that we've established that these
responses are functionally intact we can
use them to further study the physiology
of photoreceptors between the macular
and the periphery of the human
retina so since we know that there are
both rods and cones in these retinal
punches to isolate the cone
photoreceptors we have to use a double
flash protocol
and this is one thing that sutter
patch's analog outputs enables us to
provide
one fundamental aspect of photoreceptor
physiology and how it impacts vision is
the speed of deactivation of
phototransduction
the slowest deactivation reaction of
phototransduction is going to directly
relate to visual temporal resolution
specifically
by quantifying this in macular rods and
cones we can provide useful insights
into the maximum
temporal resolution of human high acuity
vision
in the rod dominated mouse
it was found to be the deactivation of
phosphodiesterase
but in amphibians it was found to be the
lifetime of activated
photo pigment
but in humans it was still unknown
and to do this we used a method
described by pepperberg in 1992
where we measured the time taken
by photoreceptors to recover a specific
percentage of their saturated responses
which you can see here
and this was set to 70 for rods
and 50 percent of cones
shown as t sat in these graphs
so we can see that the uh examples on
the left are rods in macular and
periphery
and using a double flash stimulus we can
do the same to get to obtain the values
for cones in macular and periphery
and using these obtained t sap values we
can then plot them against the log of
the light stimulus given
to determine this deactivation rate
and what we can see from the values here
is that the rods in macula and periphery
don't have a significant difference in
these rates
and similarly cones in macular and
periphery are not that different
so while we used healthy retina for
these studies
in the future we expect to find
differences in similar aspects of
photoreceptor physiology
that may occur in diseased retina
and that's what this donor eye prep
preparation will really allow us to
quantify and understand further
so in summary i've shown that we have an
established protocol and donor criteria
including a method of transporting
tissue to maintain the oxygenation and
nutrients
from which we reliably obtain
physiologically intact photoreceptor and
bipolar cell responses
and using this functionally intact
tissue we've also determined a novel
insight into photoreceptor function in
the human macula
the rate of the deactivation of the
longest living photo product of
phototransduction cascades
which provides the temporal resolution
of human vision in the macular and
periphery
this novel insight into human
photoreceptor physiology demonstrates
the strength of this donor tissue
recovery protocol
for future work investigating basic
human retinal physiology as well as the
more crucial work into understanding the
pathophysiology of retinal diseases
including age-related macular
degeneration
or diabetic retinopathy
and finally i'd like to acknowledge my
pi franz vinberg and our collaborator at
the scripps dr hannikin
the donor tissues supplied to our labs
are from both the san diego and utah
lion's eye banks and life sharing
as well as our funding sources
research to prevent blindness and the
national eye institute
thank you fatima for this very
interesting talk about uh
retinal electrophysiology um there are a
number of questions for both speakers so
far and i would like to encourage the
audience to
use the question function in the sidebar
on the left to post more questions
to the two talks that have done so far
and also let me switch to the third talk
that will be myself and i will share my
screen
and
talk about what is hidden under the
noise the title of my talk um what is
hidden under the nor uh the noise my
name is jan dolce product manager for
patch cam systems etc instrument the
inspiration for this talk came from
questions that i keep getting asked in
tech support a lot of it is hey i have
this weird signal component
is it possible the amplifier is broken
and most of the time it's not because
the noise comes from somewhere else and
what i will do is i will take a
pragmatic approach
and that is based on
the
uh
the idea of my talk is in essence to
give you a couple means to
denoise your own rig that's why i will
not so much focus on the science the
rocket science behind what makes up
noise but mostly on pragmatic approaches
i will very briefly introduce of what is
noise then talk about mechanical noise
and here i present one case study
microphonics
an anecdote from my own grad student
time
and then for the most part i will talk
about electrical noise and that will all
be current noise and patch clamp
recordings but all the principles i'm
going to talk about equally applied to
voltage noise in patch clamp and also
other modes of electrophysiology
and then i will talk about filtering and
the do's and most importantly the domes
and then we will have the q and a
session for the entire webinar
there are five major strategies to deal
with noise
strategy number one first and foremost
is avoid it
second strategy is avoid it
third really avoid it if you fourth
possibly can and only if that is
absolutely not possible then you want to
use filters and i will later tell you
why
but first let's look at what is noise
and how do we describe how do we
characterize it noise is any unwanted
signal component
that is superimposed on your signal of
interest your action potential a single
channel opening or something like that
it may distort or completely obscure the
signal of interest
and one parameter that describes it is
the signal-to-noise ratio that is the
signal amplitude
compared to the noise amplitude let's
take a look at an example this is a
single channel recording and if we
introduce noise in this case 800 fencer
and standard deviation then certain
components like this flickering at the
onset or these closed flickers later on
in the recording
get hard to detect already and if we
increase the noise about threefold
it gets completely impossible to even
recognize that as a single channel
recording reliably anymore
talking about noise amplitude there's
two parameters that people typically
look at one is the peak to peak noise
and the rms noise the rms noise is the
root mean square and that describes the
noise across the entire spectrum the
under consideration
that is a better measure than the peak
to peak noise even though the peak to
peak noise is
more easily recognized usually a good
rule of thumb is the peak to peak noise
is roughly six times
the rms noise
and it can directly be measured in
sutter patch in the solar patch membrane
test and if i'm not mistaken
a hiccup patch master software has the
same
when you switch the pulse type from the
usual single pulse that it would be to
rms noise it directly shows the rms
noise and this is recorded from a
d-patch amplifier system with a ref e
head stage in a 10 kilohertz band the
specification is that it's uh
about 220 femto amps so this is even
better than specification i recorded
this a couple of days ago on my desk
let's switch over to mechanical noise
there is no such thing as good vibes in
electrophysiology
vibration is usually transmitted
mechanically either over rear floor
vibration that happens at a rather low
frequency
and can be
pretty
well isolated through using an air table
a
tabletop that floats on air dampers air
cushions and here's the isolation
performance lower value means uh lower
transmissibility so better damping the
frequency range that we're looking at
here is between 10 and 70 hertz so
relatively low
frequency you can also have mechanical
vibration
the mechanical noise
by fans or other equipment that touches
components i have i once had a fan duct
sitting on the lamp housing of a
microscope that gave me a lot of grief
or microphonics and also that gave me a
lot of grief and that's a
an anecdote a case study that i want to
elaborate a little further on at the
beginning of my grad student time i
recorded from taste buds on the red
tongue and i used a recording chamber
made of silgaard that's a polymer that's
used in electronics for isolation that
was glued on a microscope slide in this
case the red tongue was inserted on one
end of the chamber the chamber was
filled with saline with red winger
and then
the amplifier setup
looked like this the
recording electrode was actually in the
bath
for reasons i forget that was just the
established method in the lab back then
and the
electrode that was in touch with the
actual taste bud was grounded
and the whole thing set on a stage that
was also grounded and of course that
causes a capacitance between the
conductor here and the grounded stage
and what happened over time is the
bottom of the recording chamber detached
from the microscope slide
and
the way i noticed that was because i've
suddenly
saw myself talking or somebody talking
in the hallway or even just walking past
in the hallway i saw that on my
electrophysiological signal
and that was because this membrane here
created a perfect capacitive microphone
sound waves would compress the air and
then the capacitance between the path
chamber solution and the grounded stage
would
cause a capacitive microphone that i
would see
in my recorded signal
the fix was easy just cutting out the
bottom here but finding what the problem
was took me i think it was about two
weeks or something like that
let's switch over to electrical noise
excuse me
electrical noise comes either as
intraneous noise and there could be
instrument noise or there's a number of
other noise
forms that we don't want to deal with
here today because those are not things
that we can
pragmatically fix fixing our own setup
but i'm going to refer to the axon guide
that
has a lot of detail about what they do
and where they play a role
but what i do want to talk about is
electrode noise
and aliasing and often
overlooked form of noise
and then there's extraneous noise and
most predominantly line frequency hum
and uh briefly also talk about other
noise sources
and this is really what's predominant in
tech support most of the time what
people encounter is line frequency
helmet that's also because it's so
ubiquitous
so let's talk about instrument noise the
car won't go faster than its top speed
or for the amplifier that means the
noise you're going to achieve is not
going to be lower than what the
amplifier
gives you the amplifier noise
performance so looking at the frequency
response of an amplifier system
in this case this is a d-patch that's
the same
e-patch that
i
showed a picture of earlier
and there are two of it has a total of
three feedback ranges two are shown here
this is the resistive range with the 500
megome in blue the 500 mega ohm feedback
resistor and this is the capacitive
range with the feedback capacitor
and the noise is much lower with the
feedback capacitor and also the
bandwidth is much higher and the rev e
head stage was specified at over 500
kilohertz bandwidth the
later revisions have a full megahertz
that means that curve would just
continue rising all the way to one
megahertz here
and this was measured open circuit in a
grounded enclosure
why do we do that are we trying to cheat
to get the best possible noise no the
simple reason is we want to describe an
amplifier property not the environment
and if we
measured it uh in anything other than a
shielded enclosure and open circuit we
would not measure the amplifier
performance but
something that we pick up from the
outside and if you don't have a nice box
like this aluminum foil wrapped around
the head stage and ground it does a
similarly good job
now um we're gonna see so let me back up
here
we're gonna see a number of these
spectra in this case it's a
power
spectral density um
plot we're gonna see a number of these
spectra and that's why i do want to
switch back a little bit to theory but
in the pragmatic approach i will not go
all the way into math but
visually show you how a complex signal
such as our electrophysiological signal
is composed of multiple components at
discrete frequencies
excuse me
so i will show you how you come from
a sine wave that is a signal with a
single
frequency and a certain amplitude
to a square
pulse which is a complex signal
that has multiple
uh frequency components so what we'll do
is we'll compose a complex waveform out
of a sine wave single frequency single
amplitude we'll add a second one
and the third one a fourth a fifth and
so on
put that in the big blender
and out comes
an action potential
or
single channel recording
or maybe sodium currents
or in our as in our example that square
wave that is a complex as an example
simple example of a complex signal so
what we're going to do is we'll take a
sine wave one frequency certain
amplitude
and
put
a second sine wave over it superimpose a
second sine wave higher frequency
smaller amplitude and if we add these
two up we get the blue the resulting
curve here we do that again higher
frequency smaller amplitude we add it up
one more time higher frequency smaller
amplitude and it's easy to see how this
becomes more and more square and if we
keep going a couple more times we end up
with that
so
that is in essence a complex signal that
is composed of discrete individual
frequencies and if we do the whole thing
in reverse we end up what's done with a
four-year transformation that's the same
principle
except applied the other way around we
deconvolute a complex signal into its
individual components so this signal the
postsynaptic events
can be deconvoluted into a spectrum in
this case the y scaling is different the
magnitude but the power spectral density
would look the same would have the same
shape the
frequency axis in this case is linear
and what we get is we get individual
peaks
that stick out over the overall
contribution here and this describes uh
what's what's in this signal so we'll
see a couple curves off of this and i
just wanted to make sure that you
understand all understand what they mean
let's go back this is the same curve
that i showed earlier and the red curve
here the with the capacity feedback in
in the d patch let's go back and take a
look at what happens if we put a pipette
holder on the head stage and again this
is a question that a custom in tech
support recently
asked
and well
again the pipette holder i wanted to
investigate the pipette holder so the
pipette holder went in in the shielded
box as well and what happens is it
doesn't really add that much noise the
exon guide says it's about 10 percent
it's it looks like it's a it's less than
that but it's across the entire spectrum
with a polycarbonate pipette holder we
also make quartz holders and this
superimposed now on in in green
is virtually identical to the
polycarbonate holder not too surprising
since the whole thing is in the air so
under the material the dielectric
constant we'll get to that in a second
does not play that big of a role so the
quartz pipette holder is
important for mechanical stability in
terms of noise performance it doesn't do
a whole lot
let's take a look at electrode noise the
the electrode is
both a
resistor and a capacitor
let's first look at how the the pipette
is a capacitor and creates capacitive
current noise and that is prep
proportional to the square of the
capacitance here is the formula that
describes the
power spectral density and here's the
capacitance that goes into it
in square and that's the important thing
that we need to remember capacitance
determines the capacity of the
dielectric noise the resistance also
does
that's the
electrode voltage noise here
we'll look at that when we look at how
the pipette is a resistor the capacitor
we may remember from high school those
capacitive capacitors with two
metal discs
conductors
separated by an
isolator in this case
air in air gap
and the
we probably inserted different materials
here to see how that changed and the
symbol in a circuit diagram is this this
is a capacitor and if we look at our
pipette this is a patch pipet that is
filled with intracellular solution
and immersed in a bath that
causes that that forms a capacitor with
a conductor
an isolator and another conductor
the path is grounded the pipette is
connected to the input of a head stage
of
an amplifier and of course the
capacitance is not just in this small
area of the pipette wall but distributed
evenly across the entire wall of the
pipet
and if we remember the pipette
capacitance which we want to keep low is
proportional to the area and the
dielectric constant
and inversely proportional to the
distance between the conductors so how
could we reduce the pipette capacitance
and along with that the capacitive noise
we could either
reduce the wetted area
by reducing the pipette fill height
only filling it to the minimum
or by reducing the bath level
or doing both ideally
or we could increase the wall thickness
by either using thick ball glass or by
thickening it by coating it with silgate
that's the same material that my
recording chamber in an earlier slide
was made of
and we could also use quartz capillaries
to reduce the dielectric constant
because quartz has a lower dielectric
constant than the borosilicate glass
that's used for a conventional patch
pipettes
the pipette is also a resistor as i
mentioned earlier and here's the same
equation that we had earlier and the
resistance the electro resistance here
also goes into the noise the spectral
uh density
power spectral density of
the pipette and the pipette resistance
is governed by the resistance of the tip
the diameter of the opening and also the
length of the geometry plays a little
bit of a roll
another form of
noise that's often overlooked is
aliasing aliasing what is that it's a
form of intraneous noise that happens
when you digitize your signal what
happens when you digitize a sine wave
like this is the analog digital
converter takes a reading at time zero
and
zero plus sampling interval
and at equal intervals thereafter
and it only remembers the readings at
all these time points
and discards the signal in between and
if we do that and connect the dots here
then what we see is a low frequency
signal that's not actually
present
in the original signal
the
visual analogon of that is the so called
wagon wheel effect that many of us may
remember from the western movies that
were pretty popular a couple decades ago
here also we see an artificial
slower movement than what is actually
present
in the this spinning disc in this case
how can i avoid that by applying the
so-called nyquist theorem
sample with at least twice the highest
frequency that's present in the signal
and that's shown here so again we sample
at t equals zero and
zero plus sampling interval and the
sampling interval is
twice the frequency of the sine wave and
in this case what happens is we avoid
aliasing but of course this does not
appropriately describe our signal
so what's common to do is over sampling
and uh five to ten times is a good
factor to oversample with what's shown
here is four times over sampling this
already gives us a reasonable
representation of the signal
how do i ensure that i sample high
enough that's by limiting the bandwidth
of my original
signal with a
low pass filter and that's called the
entire aliasing filter the anti-aliasing
filter must be located before
the analog digital conversion takes
place there's no way you can remove
aliasing from a signal and all patch
clamp amplifiers and
most other electrophysiology amplifiers
have a built-in low-pass filter that you
can use for this purpose the frequency
response is shown here again frequency
on the x-axis
amplitude expressed as power power
square or powers back to density on the
y-axis and we have the so-called cut-off
frequency or minus 3 db frequency from
which off from which on the frequency
response rolls off
let's switch to extraneous noise so far
we've all talked about intraneous noise
that's noise that you can't really avoid
because it's inside the system but you
can take steps to minimize it
extraneous noise can be shielded by a
faraday cage that's an enclosure made
from conductive material could be wire
mesh here or
sheet metal but then
ventilation may become an issue
it needs to be grounded and at a single
point we'll get to that in a second
ideally should be uncoupled mechanically
uncoupled from the air table to avoid
introducing vibrations the table top
usually serves as the bottom portion of
the faraday cage
and it can minimize electromagnetic
interference but not shield strong
magnetic fields
that's important to understand and the
predominant form of electrical noise
extraneous electrical noise is line
frequency hum and i labeled it patch
campus best friend the reason why is
because it'll always be with you you
can't completely get rid of it but you
can minimize it
the most important first step is to
recognize i have line frequency hum at
all i sometimes get screenshots from
customers showing something like this
and they go like what is this my
amplifier is broken um and then what i
tell them is okay this is the membrane
test i tell them choose a longer pulse
duration so you see a couple more cycles
of what could be a sine wave like
sinusoid signal
and that is line frequency hum if it
happens
at 50 or 60 hertz depending on where in
the world you are
it's line frequency
but don't always expect a sinusoidal
signal sometimes it looks like this this
is a
composite of
line frequency the base frequency with
its harmonics and in a spectrum it looks
like this this is a really bad case
where you have a high peak at the base
frequency 60 hertz in this case again
this was taken on my desk here um and
then you have harmonics integer
multiples of the base frequency at
here 120 180 to 4300 etc hertz and it
goes on the signal to that looks like in
the previous slide and if you put this
head stage into the shielded box then
you get something like this where this
is completely absent and the signal
looks more like this note that the
scaling here is totally different this
is nano amps this is about
uh
minus one to plus one nano amps and this
is a couple pico amps
so how to deal with line frequency hum
let me reiterate the most important
thing is avoid it
and avoid it by grounding and you want
to use a star topology and avoid ground
loops in your grounding scheme you want
to use banana
plugs crimp or shielded or solder
connectors no alligator clips not for
permanent connections that is
you want to keep all perfusion
components inside the faraday cage
and if that's not possible interrupt the
liquid column with an infusion dripper
like this
the downside of the perfusion dripper is
it introduces delays in the perfusion
sometimes there's also a filter in the
bottom here that tends to clog up over
time
you want to use a dedicated ground point
with a start topology here's the ground
point gp 17 that we that's that
instrument introduced a couple of years
ago ago and again you only want to have
one point to the amplifier signal ground
so your ground point in the faraday cage
all equipment in the cage
shall be connected to that and then
there must be a single connection to the
amplifier signal ground usually in the
back
and then all components in the rack or
on the shelf that the amplifier sits are
also grounded to this ground point
and only one path so here what you would
create is a ground loop nope
you don't want to have that you don't
want to do that
um you may also have to
lift the signal ground from the earth
ground or the chassis ground here shown
the deep the back of the d-patch
amplifier system there's this little
bracket that lets you connect or
disconnect that
you don't as i mentioned want to use
alligator clips for permanent ground
connections
they have small contact points create an
unstable connection that tends to slip
off usually unnoticed and then you spend
a long time troubleshooting
because they cause intermittent or high
resistance contacts so don't use this
use this
have a banana instead
how can you troubleshoot persistent
noise
you want to run a membrane test or
another mode that lets you continuously
monitor the signal
if you have use an oscilloscope my
experience shows that these don't exist
anymore in a lot of electrophysiology
labs
you want to turn off and unplug
everything electrical and watch your
signal change
if it changes when you unplug something
then there you have your culprit
you want to touch blank metal surfaces
with a grounded wire and again see how
the signal changes when i touch this
screw near
my objective
mount and on the microscope and all of a
sudden my line frequency hum goes goes
away then there you have your culprit
and for this it's okay to use an
alligator clip only if you have
identified a component then use a banana
or some other more reliable connector
you
want to move a grounded sheet of
aluminum foil around the head stage to
get an idea what direction the noise may
come from
and you may have to connect or
disconnect the signal ground in the
earth ground at the back and also what
helps is removing individual ground
wires to detect ground loops in general
you want to
not leave ground wires in place that
don't give you a benefit if it doesn't
make it better then there's a pretty
good chance
that uh it makes it worse
and with that what i'll do is um i will
skip ahead a little bit uh skip the
second use case scenario
um
leak subtraction and go to other sources
of extraneous noise
fluorescent light fixtures are pretty
popular
air conditioning equipment heating and
air conditioning equipment climate
chambers oftentimes have switching
noise that you that may even get
transmitted through the um the ac lines
large scientific instruments like
ultracentrifuges and they also tend to
produce
large magnetic fields elevators are
pretty notorious cell phones used to be
really bad they've gotten a whole lot
better
a subway a street car railway i recently
visited a lab in israel and then they
were concerned because they were
building a
railway line a
small
a light rail line
that was supposed to run right outside
the
two electrophysiology labs and that
could cause a lot of trouble and and and
you name it
let's take a really quick look at
filtering is it a necessity or is it a
last resort
this is a slide that i already showed um
you want to limit the bandwidth
of your signal to what's relevant for
your signal of interest there's no point
recording a slow signal such as her
currents at an excessive bandwidth like
50 kilohertz or something like that and
you can use the same low pass filter
that serves as your anti-aliasing filter
also keeps your files small
and if you have to use what's called a
hum filter then you want to use a method
that creates a template and subtracts it
that is implemented in the molecular
devices digidata 1550
in the humbuck from quest scientific
that's been around for like ever
and also in software at no additional
cost in sutter patch software but
my recommendation is don't use it
notch filters are ineffective and prone
to introducing artifacts so those you
definitely don't want to use you always
want to retain the unfiltered signal too
so if you use a hardware item
then um record the the original signal
in addition to the
filtered signal
and you still want to minimize the noise
in your rig first and not rely on the
filter alone the smaller the line
frequency hum is that goes into one of
these
methods
the better the result
and
yeah i
can only say it again try to do without
in summary i talked about mechanical
noise electrical noise and filtering
and now we're going to switch to the
question answer session and the
discussion and i hope there's going to
be a lot of interesting questions here
thank you very much for your attention
thank you jan uh so there there are a
number of questions we're going to
probably run into a time
issue here so we'll get to a few of the
questions any questions that we do not
answer live will be answered by email
so the first question is for fatna can
you detect any other retinal neurons
during ex-vivo erg
uh yeah thanks so that's a great
question
with in vivo g you can detect a various
different components one of which is uh
the
oscillatory potential um and you don't
actually get that
um in xvivo yaji
so primarily what you're going to be
looking at is the photoreceptor and
bipolar cell responses and also um
you can if you don't include any drugs
detect the
um potassium currents in um
the malaglia of the retina
thank you so here's a quick question for
the 721 from that i could quickly answer
uh what is the wavelength switching time
so on the 721 the switching time is less
than four microseconds it's pretty fast
i have a question here for yan
in some labs i have seen everything
wrapped in aluminum foil does that have
an effect on reducing hum
it definitely doesn't have an effect on
reducing hum if you're lucky it doesn't
have an effect at all
um if you're unlucky it
tends to create ground loops so that is
pretty close to voodoo um
one of the slides i
skipped
one of the the items i skipped was not
doing a rain dance that that usually
doesn't help
um and wrapping everything in an
aluminum foil particularly if the
aluminum foil is not grounded is
unnecessary
ineffective at best and
can create more noise
and for the most part
like amplifier systems the amplifier
case is grounded anyway so totally
unnecessary don't do that
oh here's another question for you the
setter patch have a real-time fft
function similar to a spectrum analyzer
a very good question that's
related to what i showed how the
complex signal is composed of individual
components and
that's actually a really good
feature suggestion
um i can see a challenge implementing a
user interface
that makes it um
reasonably easy to define and intuitive
to define what exactly you want to
analyze um because
[Music]
running fft even though f is the first f
stands for fast takes a little bit of
time and if you have a very large data
set then running an fft would take quite
a bit of time so you would have to
define a subset of your data that you
want to analyze but yeah let's look into
that i'll put that on the list of
feature suggestions from customers
great thank you so i have two questions
here for you fatino
can you clarify how you distinguish
between rod and cone responses
uh yeah so that would be a combination
of uh two things
so um like i showed earlier in the
presentation
rod photoreceptors have a much longer
response time in response to light
stimuli
um whereas the cones are a much sharper
response and they recover much faster so
you can use both
the uh the length of the response to
your stimulus but also the intensity of
the stimulus so rods are much more
sensitive to than cones
so uh once you step up your light
intensity you'll sweep that you'll see a
switch as well between these longer rod
responses to a much sharper much faster
cone response
thank you here's question number two for
you we already have a sutter instrument
amplifier system how can we convert our
system to do x vivo erg
uh yeah so that is a combination of um a
few different things
uh so obviously you'll if you don't
already have one you'll need um a light
stimulus setup so
they're pretty easy to set up and
there's a few
different companies that will
make systems that you can kind of piece
together around your existing setup
and then the second thing is a
differential
amplifier
um and sorry a third thing as well is
the specimen holder so the specimen
holder um we have cnc drawings that
we're happy to share with other labs to
um
to 3d print your own or if you have a
machine shop at your university or
institution they can also make it from
the cnc drawings that we're happy to
share
um and there's uh making the electrodes
that go into that and then also the
perfusion lines it's a really easy
process that you can um piece together
yourself and we're happy to help people
do that
we also have there's a few jov
papers that france has published in the
past to take you step by step through
what you'll need to do to adapt your
system to be able to do x vivo yagi
great thank you
john here's another one for you i
learned that pouring oil on the bath
also helps reduce noise can you explain
that and what are the disadvantages
yes the effect there is the same as
with using silgaart you have a
hydrophobic substance
that prevents the meniscus that i showed
in that
one graphic the bath creeping up on the
pipette particularly what i showed the
pipette vertical vertical
but in reality it's at an angle and that
means you can have quite a bit of liquid
being sucked up there the oil would
minimize that the disadvantage of the
oil other than creating a mess of course
is if you have
a solution that's not hydrogenated
as it is common in slice
electrophysiology but if you work with
cultures for example
i said hydrogenate oxygenated of course
um then your cells may run out of oxygen
and that of course isn't all that great
for them
okay thank you um here's a question that
i will tackle uh is a software available
for controlling the lambda 10 3 and
lambda 10b
oh yeah there's many different packages
out there that support uh the the lambda
filter wheels um for
from sutter itself we have
as i mentioned we have an xop that can
do it through igor that would allow you
to control it we also have a
usb driver that will allow you to
to control the filter wheel actions
yourself via a set of commands so those
are available no charge for my website
oh here's another follow-up question on
that and they have a wheel that is not
stable how to fix that problem
um
stability issues i mean are it would
depend
it could be a problem with the wheel
itself or it could be the way that the
filters are mounted causing an imbalance
in the weight and depending on the cube
there is some i believe there's some
faq information on our website under the
imaging section that talks about this
but if not please reach out to to one of
our tech people
either at the info etc.com or you can
look up the product manager's direct
email on our website
another
question that i would like to tackle is
a question if the if the 721 is
available in the rackmount version
currently no it's just a desktop version
and i think we have enough time for
maybe uh
one more question and i see here um
another question regarding the led cubes
uh how long does it take to exchange an
led cube in the seven two one uh as i
mentioned in the talk it's a two-less
operation so all you have to do is
remove the four loosen the four screws
to remove the top cover and then two
screws that actually hold down the led
cube i think it should take actually
less than a minute to do the whole thing
ah what it seems to me i think we should
stop at this time we're already more
than 15 minutes over and i apologize
most of that
was on my part
or are there any uh other questions that
you think
we should answer here okay then we
should probably answer the rest of them
uh as i mentioned we'll be answering the
rest of them by email directly to the
person who asked it
okay so then thank you very much
everybody for attending today and you
have a great day or for those of you in
europe a great evening i see one person
even dialed in from india at least
that's late evening
or good night i could say
thank you very much goodbye
you